Speaker 1: Looking forward to 2024. More and
more Republicans are saying Donald Trump's
not going to be the Republican nominee. Now I'm
able to find no data that points that way. But
let's take it a step at a time, as I like to do,
and start with the claims that are being made.
There's an article on the Hill from this morning.
A growing number of Republicans say Trump won't be
the Republican nominee. Former Speaker Speaker
Paul Ryan, former Florida Governor Jeb Bush,
former Vice President Mike Pence. In recent
days, each indicated they'd rather see someone
else on the ballot in the next presidential
election. Some of the most outspoken figures
like Ryan Bush and Congresswoman Liz Cheney are
no longer standard bearers of the party which
has been taken over by Trump. Exactly. But they
still carry large megaphones. There are concerns
about another Trump candidacy, combined with
polls showing many voters are ready to move on.
Illustrate how Trump's viability as a candidate
could shape how the primary comes into focus.
Former House Speaker Newt Gingrich said Some
people like Trump and some people don't like
Trump. He's the most dominant single figure in the
party, and that's a fact. We played the clip a few
days ago of Mike Pence saying, well, there might
be somebody else. I'd prefer more. When he was
asked about supporting Trump in 24. Pence may be
planning to run himself. Paul Ryan, speaking about
24, says, I think Trump's unelect ability will be
palpable by then. We all know he will lose. Or let
me put it this way, we all know he's much more
likely to lose the White House than anybody else
running for president on our side of the aisle.
So why would we want to go with that? And then you
can find other people. Joe O'Day, the Republican
Senate candidate in Colorado, says, I don't think
Trump should run again. Mitch McConnell has kind
of played coy with it. Lindsey Graham says we have
a pretty good chance with Trump running, but
pretty good chance isn't necessarily the best
thing. So the most important question is how are
they going to stop him if he runs? They can barely
stand up to him now when he's not even running
for anything. Do we really imagine them standing
up to Trump after he announces? Not really. Do
we imagine them standing up to Trump after he
survives longer than a few other candidates who
who start to drop out and the support consolidates
around Trump the way we saw it in 2016. I don't
know that I see it. And most importantly, look at
the polling data that we have. 2024 presidential
nomination. We have polling from from this month.
There's a New York Times Siena poll from this
month. There's a Harris poll from this month in
the New York Times Siena poll. Trump is leading
by 23. With the Santas at 26. So it's Trump 49,
DeSantis 26. In the Harris poll, Trump is leading
by 38. That doesn't really look like Republican
voters are ready to abandon Trump. If you look
at the betting markets, the betting markets,
those are asking the question, not who do you
support in 24, but who do you believe will win?
It's basically a dead heat between DeSantis and
Trump. So the most optimistic data we can find
is that the betting markets predict that, dawg.
Say it's basically a toss up. But then you also
look at some of the other latest polling, and
this is polling on hypothetical matchups. Now,
this is who could win, who could win in 2024?
There there is an argument maybe for someone other
than Trump, because you look at recent polling,
Emerson College says if the race were today,
Biden beats Trump by three Yahoo! News. If
the race is today, Biden beats Trump by two.
So the best case would be there isn't great
polling for Trump winning in a rematch,
but it is very early and there's almost 15, 12,
12 to 14% undecided. When you pull people today,
part of me wants Trump to run because there's
a real chance that DeSantis would fare better
against the eventual Democratic nominee. At the
same time, crazy things can happen and anybody can
end up winning, as we have learned and as we have
seen. So it's really up to Republicans. I don't
have advice for them. I think Trump is vulnerable
if he is the nominee. But maybe that's a reason
that we want to see him run if we're looking from
the left. But the most important question to the
Republicans and it's up to them to figure it out,
I'm not giving them advice. If you really don't
want Trump to run or you don't want him to be
the nominee, what can you actually do to dissuade
Republican voters from supporting him? Because
as of right now, there is clear support behind
only one candidate, and that's Trump. There is a
smaller but still statistically significant amount
of support behind DeSantis. No one else is polling
greater than five or 6%. I know we're two years
away, but I don't understand how they stop Trump
if Trump wants it. Let me know your thoughts.